everyone and welcome to today's live
broadcast targeting the blood-brain
barrier transferrin receptor or delivery
of biologics while our dimers disease
presented by Richie Casa Maria she is an
assistant professor at the Keck Graduate
Institute School of Pharmacy
I am Marjorie Torres of laggards and I
will be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
Lavery's labyrinth is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want and any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen in tagra
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen well answer as
many questions since we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located in the promotional
board at the bottom or center of your
screen or use the ask the question box
to let us know that you're having a
problem this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located in the top
right corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
a cheap-ass embryo I will now turn the
presentation over to her hello everybody
today I will be talking about trance
targeting the blood brain barrier
transferrin receptor to deliver
biologics for Alzheimer's disease I have
nothing to disclose so everyone knows
that Alzheimer's disease is the leading
cause of dementia worldwide and is a
progressive neurodegenerative disorder
this particular list of drug candidates
was taken from Alzheimer's drug
discovery foundation that was published
very recently and according to that
particular report that was published
they were about 126 drug candidates that
were under clinical development for
Alzheimer's disease just in the year
2017
and if you look at this particular list
what you notice is that drug candidates
that target amyloid or tau or meanly
biologics as observed with this
particular red box here and none of
these drugs have actually been approved
for the treatment of Alzheimer's disease
who date but what you notice is that
most of the drugs that are under
clinical development for Alzheimer's
disease are large molecule or biologics
and none of these have been approved by
the FDA for the treatment of Alzheimer's
disease and one of the key reasons for
the failure of biologics for any neuro
degenerative disorder including
Alzheimer's disease is the presence of
the blood-brain barrier so what is a
blood-brain barrier but brain barrier is
a barrier that separates the blood from
the pet separates the brain from the
peripheral circulation and the initial
work that was done to show the presence
of the blood-brain barrier was done over
100 years ago by Paul Ehrlich and his
student got Goodman and they showed
using lipophilic dyes that the
blood-brain barrier was basically
present between the blood and the
peripheral circulation and when these
lipophilic died when these hydrophilic
dyes were injected in the brain they did
not reach the peripheral circulation or
when these hydrophilic dyes were
injected in the peripheral circulation
they really did not reach the brain
indicating the presence of a barrier
subsequent work basically shows sort of
the anatomical site for the blood-brain
barrier was a cerebral micro vasculature
and the endothelial cells that line the
blood vessels of the blood of the brain
micro vasculature so this figure here
basically shows you the presence of the
blood-brain barrier or the cells and
make up the neurovascular unit that
today make up the blood-brain barrier
and you can see that this capillary
lumen here is lined by the endothelial
cells and these endothelial cells are
cemented together by very tight
junctions and lining these the capillary
Numan are parasites and both the
parasites and the endothelial cells are
encased in a basement membrane and
outside the basement membrane are
astrocyte foot processes so what you
notice is that the micro vasculature or
the cerebral micro vascular is actually
very different from the peripheral micro
vasculature
making the blood-brain barrier actually
very very tight and thus preventing the
delivery asks large molecules as well as
small molecules into the brain it is
actually well known the 98% of small
molecules and hundred-percent of large
molecules do not cross the blood-brain
barrier as a result of which the
blood-brain barrier actually is the
major obstacle to CNS drug delivery
today now the problem of the blood-brain
barrier bottleneck is evident from this
particular figure that was taken from a
paper published by Bill Partners screw
where a mouse was injected with 14c
histamine which is a pretty small
molecule if you look at the molecular
weight of histamine it is only 111
Dalton's which indicates it's a very
small molecule and this 14c histamine
was allowed to circulate in the mouse
for about five minutes after IV
injection and then a complete body
autoradiogram was performed look at this
complete body autoradiogram you can see
that the 14c is being readily
distributed throughout the body however
does not enter the brain and the spinal
cord again underscoring the problem of
the blood-brain barrier bottleneck
showing that a small molecule like
histamine also does not penetrate the
blood-brain barrier so if a lot of these
drugs under clinical development for
Alzheimer's disease are biologics
meaning large molecules how they how do
we really expect these large molecules
to penetrate the blood-brain barrier and
be developed as therapeutics for
Alzheimer's disease now out of the
various approaches that are used to
deliver biologics into the brain one of
the approach is to target endogenous
that brain barrier receptors for drug
delivery and this is the major focus of
the talk today so there are different
receptors that can be targeted for the
delivery of large molecules for example
the transferrin receptor or the insulin
receptor and today I will be focusing on
the transferrin receptor which is highly
expressed at the blood-brain barrier the
reason for selection of transferrin
receptor or insulin receptor for drug
delivery is that these receptors are
receptor mediated transit OSes system
meaning that once a ligand or a receptor
that binds to these once the ligand or a
monoclonal antibody binds to these
scepters are expressed on the
blood-brain barrier these ligands or
marker antibodies and then ferried into
the brain because these receptors
undergo receptor mediated transit OSes
and not under psychosis which will mean
that the cargo is stuck within the
endothelial cells so in this particular
talk I will be focusing on the use of
monoclonal antibodies against the
transferrin receptor to deliver drugs
into the brain so in our lab we focus on
several biologics for the treatment of
Alzheimer's disease and I this table
here just lists a different biologic
class that we are interested in in our
lab and we are interested in delivering
you know show things including the
through poety or BDNF which have which
our protective or studies have shown
that these may be protective in for
Alzheimer's disease we will also focus
we also focus in our lab on delivery of
decoy receptors for example a TNF alpha
decoy receptor which is a TNF alpha
inhibitor that is etanercept for
Alzheimer's disease and we also focus on
the delivery of therapeutic antibodies
which are actually at the forefront of
drug delivery or drug development for
Alzheimer's disease for example
anti-amyloid antibodies anti cow
antibodies again these are large
molecules and we make use are targeting
the transferrin receptor at the
blood-brain barrier to get these across
into the brain and these and the drugs
highlighted in red are the ones I'm
going to be talking specifically about
in this particular presentation the
first part of my talk will focus on
targeting the blood-brain barrier
transparent receptor to deliver TNF
alpha inhibitors for Alzheimer's disease
the Y will be particularly particularly
interested in delivering TNF alpha
inhibitors for Alzheimer's disease this
is because a lot of pre clinical and
experimental Alzheimer's disease book
shows the TNF alpha actually plays a
role in several stages of Alzheimer's
disease pathogenesis for example if you
look at this particular flowchart here
you can see that TNF alpha is implicated
in abnormal ABI processing in Phanatic
loss iran and loss and dysfunction and
neuronal cell death and all these events
collect
dimension so it would be it sounds
pretty reasonable to target tnf-alpha
for Alzheimer's disease because of the
central role that she NFL for plays and
now Simon Says II and if you look at the
current leagues insane tnf-alpha
inhibitors what you notice is that these
TNF alpha inhibitors that are currently
approved by the FDA today our biologic
trucks for example it can accept which
is TNF alpha to PI receptor or in
flexsim ad which is a monoclonal
antibody against TNF alpha and even
though these a biologic TNF alpha
inhibitors have been approved by the FDA
for peripheral inflammatory conditions
that Crohn's disease or rheumatoid
arthritis
none of these biologic TNF alpha
inhibitors have been approved for CNS
diseases including Alzheimer's disease
in spite of the central role of TNF
alpha in Alzheimer's disease
pathogenesis or other or pathogenesis of
other CMS diseases and this is because
the biologic TNF alpha inhibitors are
large molecules or biologics that do not
cross of that brain barrier so if one
had to develop these existing biologic
TNF alpha inhibitors for Alzheimer's
disease heath biologic TNF alpha
inhibitors include a etanercept which is
a teen of alpha equal receptor have to
be re-engineered for blood-brain barrier
penetration and this is what we did in
our lab we engineered it an recept or
the extracellular domain of the type to
human TNF alpha receptor for blood-brain
barrier penetration by fusing it to a
monoclonal antibody against the mouse
transferrin receptor so this cartoon
here just shows you how this fusion
protein is now delivered to the brain so
this is a fusion protein that was
engineered and one part of one domain of
the fusion protein you can accept or the
TNF alpha decoy receptor or your
biologic charm and the other domain of
this fusion protein is the monoclonal
antibody against a mass transfer
receptor so once this fusion protein is
injected system systemically so keep in
mind that this fusion protein can be
injected systemically and we don't have
to use invasive routes for example the
intracerebral ventricular route to
administer this fusion floatie so once
this fusion protein is injected it's
sistemics is
chemically it goes and binds to the
transferrin receptor that is
overexpressed of the blood-brain barrier
and since this transferrin receptor is
known to undergo receptor mediated non
cytosis the scar bow or the fusion
protein is then delivered on the brain
side and once in the brain side the
tnf-alpha
inhibitor domain of the future protein
and then sequester exists in the Alpha
which can then be used to prevent the
various steps or various targets in the
pathophysiology of Alzheimer's disease
using this approach we engineered
solution proteins of the brain
penetrating TNF alpha inhibitor and our
monoclonal antibody against a mouse
transferrin receptor
however after engineering these fusion
proteins it's really important to make
sure that these fusion proteins which in
high affinity to their target which in
this case is TNF alpha so we performed
radio like and we performed radio lying
and binding receptor assays and we found
that this TNF alpha inhibitor that is
being penetrating and the non been put
in front ready in a pathway inhibitor
which is Tanner Sam both bound to TNF
alpha with very low dissociation
constants which were in the picomolar
range knowing that the fusion protein on
the green finish making form of this it
honor self retained high affinity for
TNF alpha which is exactly what we want
so after after making sure that
engineering of these fusion proteins
have simply training
affinity for chain of alpha we then
perform pharmacokinetic studies both in
primates as well as in mice to make sure
that there was enough brain uptake of
this fusion protein in the brain and
also that the stability of this fusion
protein was maintained in in plasma over
a suitable period of time so this bar
graph basically shows you the form of
brain uptake of this fusion protein of
the brain penetrating format of each
other cept in primates and what u s--
notice is that the non brain penetrating
form form of this biologic TNF alpha
inhibitor which is just the key Tanner
cept on its own has a very low grain
uptake which is less than 0.5 percent ID
per 100 gram of primate brain however
when we
we engineer etanercept for blood-brain
barrier penetration you can see the
brain penetration the brain update of
his brain penetrating etanercept was
about 2% which is much much higher than
the than the brain uptake of non brain
penetrating he Turner step which was
best in point five percent ID 400 parent
brain and you're the control that we
used was just the isotope control our
human IgG which also has a very
low-grade uptake who had a very similar
to the brain update of the non brain
penetrating Tanner sent after showing
that this penetrating etanercept on
etanercept news to the monoclonal
antibody against the transferrin
receptor has a high brain uptake we then
perform detailer pharmacokinetic studies
in mice determine the most appropriate
hour of administration for Alzheimer's
but this is because Alzheimer's disease
is a chronic neurodegenerative disease
and an IV doubt of administration may
not be the most preferred route of
administration because we require
continuous administration of this brain
penetrating biologic TNF alpha inhibitor
so when we perform pharmacokinetic
studies in mice we wanted to study other
routes of administration for example the
intra peritoneum or the subcutaneous
startup administration to determine
which is the most appropriate route of
administration for chronic dosing and we
tested different doses of the brain
penetrating gene F alpha inhibitor that
is 0.73 and 10 milligram per kilogram in
mice both using the IP route and the
sub-q route of administration and what
we found was that the 3 milligram per
kilogram dose of the brain penetrating
TNF alpha inhibitor resulted in a very
good brain uptake and also high plasma
stability as evident from the from the
red boxes here you can see that both the
IP and the sub-q routes of
administration resulted in comparable
brain uptake of about 0.7% of about 0.7
a microgram per gram brain in a mouse
and we also had high pass must a belief
of about 85 of about 82 to 89 percent in
mice over a period of 24 hours which is
which is very favorable so
for deciding that the IP or the sub-q
out of administration was actually
suitable for the administration of this
biologic tnf-alpha inhibitor we then
perform studies in a mouse model of
Alzheimer's disease to see if this brain
penetrating TNF alpha inhibitor offered
any therapeutic benefits in this
particular mouse model so for the
purpose of our study we made use of the
double transgenic mouse model of
Alzheimer's disease and these mice
express the human amyloid precursor
protein and the mutant precentor than
one and these mice develop abundant
amount of amyloid plaque by the time
they're 6 months of age and plaque load
keeps increasing with time so we made
use of male double transgenic mice and
these mice for 6 months at the start of
the study when the my start developing
plaque and these mice were treated for a
period of 12 weeks of 3 months and we
had 3 different experimental arms the
first arm was my support Rita just with
saline that was a control group the
second set of mice were treated with the
brain penetrating TNF alpha inhibitor
that was fused basically to the Malakal
antibody against the mass transfer in
receptor and the last group of mice were
treated with a Tanner set which is a non
brain penetrating form of the biologic
TNF alpha inhibitor and these mice were
treated three days a week into
peritoneum lead for three months and at
the end of three months we had various
endpoints that were of interest to us
for example we wanted to determine the
effect on memory by performing normal
object recognition tasks we also
measured the extent of amyloid load the
extent of neural information that brain
barrier disruption and development of
cerebral microhemorrhages in these mice
and since we were dealing with antibody
therapeutics it was very important for
us to measure anti-drug antibody
formation in mice after chronic
treatment so this slide just shows you
the effect of the brain penetrating TNF
alpha inhibitor on mature a beta plaque
in these mice and mature a beta plaque
was assessed in this particular Mouse
model using five flavin which
specifically stains for mature a beta
plaque and you can see from this from
these fluorescent images that more in
the core
taste in the hippocampus we see a
reduction in the title even as mature
plaques both in the minds treated with
the brain penetrating TNF alpha
inhibitor and eat honor said immense
once we quantified these fluorescent
images you can see from the bar graphs
that the cortical high flavin positive
area was significantly lower both in the
green penetrating and the non brain
penetrating TNF alpha inhibitor groups
and also the number of pi flavin
positive stains was significantly lower
both in the brain penetrating and the
non-print print radius how flavin
treatment groups and this was true both
in the cortex and in the hippocampus
so in short both the brain penetrating
and the non-print penetrating form of
the biologic TNF alpha inhibitor caused
a reduction in mature a beta plaque as
assessed by the 5-11 and staining next
we were interested not only in measuring
the mature a beta plaque but also the a
beta peptide load itself in the brain of
in the brains of these mice and we did
this by performing the six Ethan
immunostaining or immunofluorescence
stains and you can look at these you can
see these fluorescent images and you can
see that these mindset for nine month
old at the time of sacrifice develop a
very very large amount of MA amyloid
beta peptide load as evident from these
fluorescent stains you're both in the
cortex and in the hippocampus and once
we quantify these images to know the
amount of 6010 positive stains or six
teeth and positive load both in the
cortex and hippocampus are the results
were actually pretty interesting what we
notice is that it was only in the mice
that were treated with the green
penetrating TNF alpha inhibitor then we
saw a reduction in the six ETA n
positive area and the number of six
keith n+ strains both in the cortex and
hippocampus we saw change towards
reduction in these parameters with the
non brain penetrating chain of alpha
inhibitor however these values did not
reach statistical significance
supporting these results we also
supporting these results what we found
was that when we performed Eliza on the
brain homogenous to detect the amount of
brain
ABA
1:42 load what we found was that it was
only in the brain penetrating tnf-alpha
and if it a group that we saw a
reduction in the brain etheta 142 load
however with a non brain penetrating TNF
alpha inhibitor we did not see any
reduction in beta 1 42 loan so this
particular slide just in short shows you
that it was only the brain penetrating
TNF alpha inhibitor that caused a
reduction in the six Ethan positive
immunostaining or and also a reduction
in a beta 142 as determined by Eliza
however the non brain penetrating form
of the biologic TNF alpha inhibitor did
not cause a significant reduction in the
six each enemy no strain or a beta 142
load in the brain homogenous and since
we were dealing with the TNF alpha
inhibitor we also wanted to measure
different different measures of neural
information and we determined the amount
of I cam 1 which is a marker of mirror
information and brain endothelial
activation and I bar 1 which is a marker
of microbial activation so if you look
at the topmost panel here what we found
was that the green eye Cameron levels
were significantly lower in the mice
that were treated with the brain
penetrating TNF I'll find it here only
however the minds have retreated with
the non brain penetrating TNF alpha
inhibitor did not show any reduction in
pain I came 1 levels so this clearly
shows you that it is a neural TNF alpha
inhibitor and not the peripheral TNF
alpha inhibitor that is implicated and I
can one brain I came 1 levels because
the green penetrating TNF alpha an
inhibitor gets into the brain however
the non-printing TNF alpha inhibitor for
example it and herself can only
neutralize better fruit skin if alpha
and not neurogenic alpha when we looked
at the green IgG levels which is a
marker of blood brain barrier disruption
what we found was that both the mice
treated with the green penetrating TNF
alpha inhibitor and Etan herself which
is a non brain penetrating TNF alpha
inhibitor had significantly lower brain
IgG levels basically indicating for
protection of blood-brain barrier or
less and destruction of blood-brain
barrier in Mouse in mice treated with
these brain penetrating and non brain
penetrating TNF alpha inhibitor
which basically suggests that it is the
peripheral tnf-alpha that is implicated
in that brain barrier disruption in this
particular mouse model because both the
brain penetrating and the non brain
penetrating chicken if alpha inhibitor
can neutralize the peripheral TNF alpha
and finally when we measured the extent
for microbial activation by performing I
Bhavani Minister chemistry very
interesting me what we found was that it
was only with a non-print penetrating
TNF alpha inhibitor that we saw a
reduction in I by one immunoreactive
area and we did not see any reduction in
the above one immunoreactive area with
the brain penetrable TNF alpha inhibitor
the reason for this is not absolutely
clear to us but this basically may
suggest that the activated I bar one of
the act will microglia in the TNF brain
penetrating TNF alpha inhibitor group
may be of the protective phenotype thus
causing a reduction in the 6010 load in
the brain but however further studies
are needed to know the kind of phenotype
that is expressed or present in the
brains of the mice that are treated with
the pre infinite reboot zenith of
inhibitor one of the major complications
associated with amyloid modifying agents
clinically has been area which is
amyloid related imaging abnormalities
which are characterized by the presence
of a cerebral microbleeds or
microhemorrhages so since the TNF alpha
inhibitors that we used in our study
caused a reduction in amyloid alone we
wanted to know if this reduction in
amyloid wound load was associated with
any kind of micro hemorrhage or micro
beat development so we performed H&E
staining and what we found was that the
top dollar on the double transgenic mice
on their own did not spontaneously
develop any micro bleeds and similarly
cronic treatment of the mice either with
the brain penetrating TNF alpha
inhibitor or the non brain penetrating
TNF alpha inhibitor which is eternal
cell did not result in any micro bleeds
or micro Hambridge development in this
particular study we also determine the
extent of antibody anti-drug antibody
formation in our study and what we
found was that four weeks after
treatment the extent of anti-drug
antibody formation was significantly
lower in the etanercept group compared
to the north through compared to the
brain penetrating TNF alpha inhibitor
group and this is expected because in
the brain penetrating TNF alpha
inhibitor group the anti drug for me
antibody formation is directed against
both the monoclonal antibody against the
Mouse transferrin receptor and the TNF
alpha decoy receptor domain of the
fusion protein however in the eternal
step treated mice the anti-drug
antibodies are directed only against the
TNF alpha inhibitor domain and hence we
see a lower anti-drug antibody formation
in the Eterna sep 2015 20 drug antibody
formation had plateaued both in the
brain penetrating and the non brain
penetrating TNF alpha inhibitor groups
and this anti-drug antibody formation
was actually pretty low titer compared
to other biologic drugs that have been
FDA approved and finally one of the key
and points that I use clinically to
assess the efficacy of a therapeutic for
Alzheimer's disease is improvement in
cognition so in this particular study we
made use of the normal object
recognition test as a measure of
recognition memory and the novel object
recognition test is based on the
inherent ability of a mouse to explore a
normal object more much more than the
old object and if a mouse explores both
the new object and an old object to the
same extent the recognition index should
be 50% so what we notice was that in
mice treated with saline and he can are
said which is a non brain penetrating
TNF alpha emitter the recognition index
was not significantly different from 50%
as as observed from the recognition
index values of 53 and 52 percent in
these experimental groups however in
mice treated with the brain penetrating
TNF alpha inhibitor the recognition
index for 68% which was significantly
higher than 50% suggesting or indicating
that these mines had were treated with
the brain penetrating TNF alpha
inhibitor had a higher preference for
the novel object compared to the old
object
so finally based on the results that we
obtained with debris and penetrating
tnf-alpha inhibitor what we found was
that both the brain penetrating TNF
alpha inhibitor that is a TNF alpha
inhibitor fused to the monoclonal
antibody against the bounced transferrin
receptor and the eternal self which is a
non brain penetrating TNF alpha TNF
alpha receptor or equally effective in
reducing Chi flavin as positive mature a
beta plaques and not been very
disruption however it was only the brain
penetrating TNF alpha editor that caused
a reduction in total a made a peptide
load as evident from the 6010 immune
stain and also reduction in insoluble a
be the 142 levels
green and common levels and most
importantly it was a paint finish rating
in F alpha inhibitor that caused an
improvement in recognition memory in the
double transgenic mouse model use in
this particular study and these
protective effects observed with a brain
penetrating TNF alpha inhibitors can be
attributed to neutralization of brain
TNF alpha since the green penetrating
TNF alpha inhibitor can bypass can move
across a blood-brain barrier and get
into the brain and neutralize TNF alpha
that is present in the brain so these
studies clearly suggests a reengineering
of a biologic TNF alpha inhibitor
into a blood brain barrier penetrable
form is really beneficial or may
actually be beneficial for Alzheimer's
disease compared to just an on been
penetrated TNF alpha inhibitor so
besides is focusing on TNF alpha
inhibitors we also focused on
development of Bane brain penetrating
anti-amyloid antibodies for Alzheimer's
disease and the reason for focusing on
developing brain penetrating
anti-amyloid antibodies for Simon's
disease is because a beta is one of them
is the pathological hallmark for
Alzheimer disease and most of the
clinical trials to date have focused on
this particular target that is amyloid
beta and most of these thin candidates
against amyloid beta have been
therapeutic antibodies against amyloid
beta however none of these have had any
success in clinical trials now this is
because amyloid anti-amyloid
antibody
large molecules that do not cross the
blood-brain barrier and hence most of
these clinical trials that have been
designed so far basically made use of
higher doses of the anti amylin antibody
to get enough into the brain and a
recent study for example the Anaconda
map study that was published recently
sure the high doses of these anti Amla
antibody result in side-effects that is
aria that is amyloid related imaging
abnormalities which are associated with
high doses of these anti amber
antibodies and because of the failure in
these anti Amla antibodies a lot of
people have now started doubting the
validity of the ambulances however in
the absence of a suitable drug delivery
strategy to get these biologics into the
brain it is really hard to conclude
whether it was insufficient delivery of
these biologics into the brain that led
to the clinical trial failure or is or
was the failure associated with or was
the failure due to the failure of the
amylin hypothesis and hence it is very
important to have an effective or a very
suitable drug delivery strategy to get
these biologics into the brain to make
sure that enough amount of these
antibodies get it gets into the brains
of patients with Alzheimer's disease and
in order to do that we engineered wind
penetrating forms of these anti-amyloid
antibodies by taking a single chain
variable fragment of the anti Amla
antibody that is directed against the
amino terminus of the e beta peptide and
fused it with the transferrin receptor
monoclonal antibody so this particular
fusion protein basically has two domains
and the transferrin receptor antibody
domain goes and binds to the blood-brain
barrier transferrin receptor resulting
in pain in influx and the amyloid anti
Amla antibody domain of the fusion
protein goes and binds to the a peer a
peptide resulting in practice
aggregation it is also important to note
that the that the ch2ch3 region of this
fusion protein goes and binds to the
neonatal FCR and receptor which results
in the e flux of this asian protein back
from
brain into the plan so after engineering
a fusion protein off the anti omelette
antibody and the monoclonal antibody
against the mouse transferrin receptor
we then wanted to determine if this
paint penetrating anti Amla antibody
offered any kind of reduction amyloid
load in a mouse model of Alzheimer's
disease and again we made use of the
double transgenic mouse model of
Alzheimer's disease and these mice were
12-month all at the time of injection
initiation by this time by 12 months all
these mice develop a lot of a beta
plaque and these mice were again treated
for about 12 weeks and we had two
different experimental arms in this
particular study one group of mice was
treated with saline that was our control
and one group of mice was treated with a
brain penetrating anti-amyloid antibody
and these mice were treated
subcutaneously every day at a dose of 5
milligram per kilogram and at the end of
the study we assess the extent of brain
and plasma the beta load and also the
development of several microhemorrhages
because that's important from the point
of view of the side effects associated
with amyloid modifying agents and we
also assess the extent of anti-drug
antibody formation in these mice this
particular figure here just shows you
the first and images of my said what she
did with saline shown in in my left
panel here and mice that were treated
with the brain penetrating anti Amla
antibody showed in the right panel here
and the top two panels here show you 5
flavin images and the bottom two panel
here shows you the 6e 10 images with
higher flavin binds to mature plaques
and 6/8 and basically labels the a beta
peptide loan and what we found was that
there was a significant reduction in the
a beta positive area and also the number
of a beer a plaque and also the average
black size in my SEPA chetan with the
brain penetrating anti Amla antibody and
this was true in the cortex as well as
in the hippocampus shown in this
particular slide here you can clearly
see that again there was a significant
reduction in 6/8 and positive area 6e
ten number of 60 10 positive facts and
also the average black size in my side
were treated with the brain penetrating
anti anger and I body compared to Saline
who chose and we obtain similar results
with higher flavin as well which are not
shown here but it's pretty evident from
from the fluorescent images that there
was a marked reduction in the thigh of
flavin known in both the cortex and the
hippocampus in the mice have retreated
with the brain penetrating anti-amyloid
antibody we also measure the amount of
plasma a beer alone in these mice and we
found no significant differences in the
a beta load in the ceiling treated mice
and myself were treated with the
anti-amyloid antibody showing that this
treatment did not result in an increase
in plasma appear alone which is often
associated with the development of
microhemorrhages with other anti a beta
therapeutics so this table here just
summarizes the summarizes the
differences between the conventional a
beer a set of anti eben a therapy that
has been under clinical development and
also receptor mediated anti but a
therapy that was described in this
particular presentation and what we
notice is that the passive immune
therapy that has been under development
for Alzheimer's disease are administered
intravenously monthly because of the
extremely long a half-life of these and
entire antibodies of about two to three
weeks
however the receptor mediated immune
therapy that was described in this
particular presentation here it's
administered subcutaneously daily
because of the receptor mediated
approach that results in a pretty short
half-life of these anti annual
antibodies of only about two to three
hours and hence these anti younger
antibodies that are brain penetrable
have to be given daily to maintain
enough exposure of the brain to these
anti-amyloid antibodies
we also found what we see what we see is
that and there is practice aggregation
with the conventional passive immune
therapy as suggested by a clinical files
and under studies and in our study we
also do poor we also found that this
receptor mediated approach also causes a
significant
disaggregation of a Vienna flag we also
notice no elevation in plasma a beta
levels with with the receptor-mediated
in therapy approach however the passive
immune therapy that is used extensively
or under clinical development for
Alzheimer's disease that's causing
elevation and plasma a beta Lord wishes
then associated with cerebral micro
Hamlisch development however we saw no
cerebral microhemorrhages with our
receptor mediated anti-amyloid antibody
this particular study and the most
important thing to highlight here is
that the anti-amyloid antibodies are
under clinical development do not bypass
the birth pain barrier or do not cross
the blood-brain barrier in the absence
of blood brain barrier disruption
however in this particular study we
engineered the anti angle antibody for
blood brain barrier penetration using
the receptor mediated approach and hence
this anti angle antibody readily crosses
the blood-brain barrier even in the
absence of blood pain and destruction
so finally based on the results shown
with the brain penetrating anti hammer
antibody or receptor mediated
anti-amyloid antibody what we found was
that these the receptor media approach
to deliver the anti-armor antibody may
result in more favorable therapeutic
indices compared to the conventional
anti amber antibody that have been at
the forefront of AD research and overall
there are several biologics and hold
promise for Alzheimer's disease but
however in the absence of a drug
delivery strategy these biologics really
cannot be developed for Alzheimer's
disease so re-engineering these
biologics for brain penetration for
example by engineering fusion proteins
of the biologic and a monoclonal
antibody against the transferrin
receptor may be a suitable approach and
may be a promising approach for the
development of these biologics for
Alzheimer's disease there are several
people who contributed to this work and
I would like to thank all the students
and the Research Associates an amount of
unit to this work at the correct
Graduate Institute I would also like to
thank my collaborators at UC Irvine
doctor Krebs and also my collaborators
at our mission technologies that is Bill
partridge
Reuben bwado and I would also like to
thank the funding agencies for providing
funds for this particular study that is
tamas associations table of Foundation
and National Institute of Aging and
start off funds provided by Keiji I
thank you very much and I would welcome
any questions now thank you doctor that
sheet INRIA for that informative
presentation it will now start to lock
you in a portion of the webinar if you
have a question you'd like to ask please
do so now just click on the ask a
question drop box located on the far
left of your presentation window type
your questions into the question into
the box that appears on your screen and
click the send button
well answer as many of your questions as
we have time for let's get started our
first question is can you comment on our
convection and delivery and interest
cerebral ventricular administration or
brain delivery
thank you for the question that's a
great question and yes in Glassell Pro
ventricular and Convention enhanced
everything has been used to deliver
large molecular weight repeat links for
example Parkinson's disease clinical
trial I can mention hands delivery and
intervention F which is drive new
traffic factor however the clinical
trials fields and subsequent studies
know that even though these routes of
administration result in to thank
delivery in the grain most of the jug
was basically concentrated around the
catheter for conventional enhancing with
me and then the drug really had to rely
on definition who's Beth throughout the
brain and hence it was no widespread
distribution of the convention enhance
Olivia in that particular file and
similarly for interest prevent the route
of admin most of the drug is actually
concentrated on Nia dependable surface
of the brain and after that the
geography has to depend on to really
stretch out the brain
and if you compare this to the
transverse cuter route that we've spoken
about in the presentation France
vascular routers else in widespread
distribution of the drug throughout the
brain and that really results in job
disappears you can compare to and
mention enhancing gives me all the
interesting event written about so the
transfer law does seem promising
intervention to the route that has been
our next question is is the molecular
Trojan horse interfered with the
indigenous margin I think that's a very
very valid question because the
endogenous ligand for the transferrin
receptor is transferrin and one question
that often comes up is if you are
targeting the transferrin receptor with
a monoclonal antibody against the
transferrin receptor with that interfere
with the functioning of the binding of
the implosion is ligand to the receptor
the transferrin receptor monoclonal
antibody is actually designed to bind to
a different site completely transparent
binding site and and hence we don't
expect any interference but we ourselves
have not done studies from that but that
it has been widely accepted that the
mortal antibody binding site it's
actually separated from the transparent
binding site thank you the next session
ends this check for the molecular
children who is objectified logic
activity of the biologic so the one of
the most important things to consider
while engineering fusion protein of the
molecular church at converse with the
biologic learned that the biologic
retains its initial biologic activity
and hence we perform a lot of different
assays to confirm that for example I
show data on the ligand receptor binding
acid that we perform to me
or that the munition of the molecular
Trojan horse with the biologic does not
alter the binding of the biologic to its
target for example alpha or the amyloid
peptide the protein should actually in
high biologic activity or high affinity
or its endogenous ligand and that's what
we see in our studies and further to
confirm it biologically active we
perform extensive pharmacological
studies it's models in Parkinson's
disease mouse models as I'm responsible
so that these fusion proteins are
actually offering therapeutic benefits
which is again a kind of an indication
of confirmation that biological biologic
activity of the of the biologic itself
is detained after fusing after injecting
a Trojan horse I would like to once
again thank dr. Richie Justin Bria for
her presentation I would also like to
thank laberd's for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through June of 2018
you'll receive an email from lamberts
letting me know on this webcast will be
available for replay make sure that
announcement we call it some madness to
they've like that that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon goodbye